are still quantifying fairness by sport
let the athletes play okay so i'm a
college athlete i played three sports in
college on top of that i play volleyball
in england i also play basketball and
this is a terrible take it's always
people that don't have to compete
against trans women that want us the
female athletes to take the risk of
competing with them i don't really need
a study to tell me that biological men
have an advantage over women any female
athlete that has competed against men at
some point knows that they have an
advantage for example my brother has not
lifted in five years
he probably still could outbench me even
though i'm a semi-pro athlete he could
take hormones for a year i guarantee he
would still be able to outlift me having
trans women compete in the women's
division puts us at a risk of being
injured we work our asses off for the
little opportunity that there is in
women's sports and men that don't even
play sports want us to just give that
away